السلام عليكم البدايه من هذا التطور
اللافت في السودان فقد قالت مصادر عسكريه
بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان قوه من الدعم
السريع اغتالت واليه غربي دارفور خبيث
ابكر بعد اختطافه عصر الاربعاء من مدينه
الجنينه الى جهه مجهوله ومن ثم تم قتله
وتصويره بعد القتله وتداول ناشطون صورا
للقبض على الوالي خميس ابكر ثم نشرت لاحقا
صور اخرى وهو مقتول
هذا الموضوع هو غيري من التطورات في
السودان مدير مكتب الجزيره في الخرطوم
المسلمي الكباشي تفاصيل ما جرى مع والي
غرب دارفور خميس ابكر
نعم هذه هي الحرب التي بدات منذ حوالي
شهرين في العاصمه السودانيه انفجرت هنا في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ثم اخذت تتمدد
وخاصه في اقليم دارفور اليوم في العاصمه
السودانيه ظلت طيران الحكومي يحلق في
السماء العاصمه ومعظمه ربما استطلاعي
ولكنه بدا يضرب مناطق مختلفه في اندرمان
وفي بحر وغيرها على الظهيره ولكن التطور
اللافت ايضا في المعارك الذي هو الذي جرى
في مدينه الربيط عاصمه الشمال
كردفان حيث غارت طيران الحكومي على مواقع
متعدده
سنخوض في هذه التفاصيل لاحقا لكن نريد كل
التفاصيل المتاحه عن اغتيال بحسب بيان او
بحسب مصادر الجيش السوداني اغتيال خميس
ابكر نريد ان نتعرف على اخر المعلومات
الوارده في هذا الشان ماذا قال الدعم
السريع ما هي الملابسات من هو خميس ابكر
السياق الذي فيه خميس ابو بكر ولمييه غرب
دارفور هو التطورات التي تحدث في عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور الجنينه منذ تقريبا اكثر
من شهر حيث القتل على الهويه هنالك وهنالك
حصار مطبق على المدينه من كل جوانبها
وهنالك
انهيار تام للخدمات في المدينه كلها خدمات
المياه والكهرباء وغير هذا هو السياق قبل
خميس ابو بكر اغتيل شقيق شقيق زعيم
المساليت والمساليت هي القبيله الاكبر في
هذه المنطقه اغتيل هذا الزعيم قبل شقيق
هذا الزعيم واليوم تم اغتيال خميسه بكر
ولولايه غرب دارفور لم تتضح الصوره بالطبع
ولكن ما قالته مثلا حركه العدل والمساواه
التي
اخرجت بيانا ادانت فيه بشده هذا الاغتيال
ان مجموعه مسلحه سمتها مليشه مسلحه على
مقر خميس ابو بكر في الجنينه واختطفته الى
مكان مجهول ثم ظهرت من بعد ذلك
ظهرت من بعد ذلك فيديوهات تداولها ناشطون
في التواصل الاجتماعي تظهر جثه لقميص بكر
وقد مثل بهذه الجثه الى الان الجيش
السوداني اتهم بشكل مباشر الدعم السريع ما
اسماه الحركه المتمرده حركه الدعم السريع
ولكن الدعم السريع قوات الدعم السريع لم
تتحدث بعد عن ماذا جرى او علمها بالذي جرى
موقفها مما جرى لي الى الان لم تصدر حركه
قوات الدعم السريع موقفا او افاده حول هذا
الموضوع ولكن السياق كله سياق
يتصاعد فيه التوتر في دارفور الجنانه
بالذات تعيش ظروف صعبه جدا تكاد تكون هذه
المدينه في طريقها الى الامحاء لان
القتل هنالك على الهويه
ومغلق الطرق حتى على الذين يودون الفرار
لا سبيل الى الفرار
خاصه الى تشاد يعني نريد معلومات عنه
من حيث وزنه في منطقه قبليه يحسب على من
من الطرف الذي قد يكون لديه رغبه في
اغتياله
خميس ابو بكر هو احد قاده الحركات المسلحه
في دارفور وحركته تسمى التحالف السوداني
هي مجموعه حركات وخميسه بكر سياسيا كان
يقف مع الاتفاق الاطاري الذي فجر الخلاف
حوله هذه الازمه والاتفاق الاطار الذي
تتبناه حركه الدعم السريع وزعيم وحميته
ولكن الان الامور تجاوزت هذا هذا هذا هذا
هذا التوصيف الاولي والمواقف الاوليه
للسياسيين والان الحرب اصبحت شامله خميس
ابو بكر هو الوالي على هذه الولايه وهو
تحدث اليوم الى احدى وسائل الاعلام وقد
ادانا واتهم بشكل واضح الدعم السريع فيما
يجري في ولايه غرب دارفور في مدينه
الجنينه
بالذات وبعدها هذه الحديث الى احدى وسائل
الاعلام
استهدف خميسا بكر
وحدث الذي حدث تم اغتياله وتصفيته بالشكل
الذي تم تداوله في وسائل الاعلام
طيب بالمسلمة ما تداعيات هذا الاغتيال
يعني ذكرت ان هناك سياق جرى فيه هذا
الاغتيال ولكن ما هي تداعياته باعتقادك
وباعتقاد المراقبين على ما يحصل لاسيما في
دارفور
بالرغم من ان التداعيات لم تظهر بعد ولم
تظهر المواقب بشكل واضح ولكن الحرب في
السودان اندفعت في اتجاه خطير وبدات تغتال
قيادات السياسيه وقيادات الحركات المسلحه
بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي
ربما قاد هذا وخاصه ان الحرف في دارفور
بالذات تقوم على اسس عرقيه سابقه هنالك من
يتحدث اليوم تحدث تحدث
مبارك المهدي قائلا ان ما يجري في دارفور
هو غزو اجنبي يريد ان ينهي وجود قبيله
المساليط ووجود سلطنه المساليد هذه
المنطقه تاريخيا هي منطقه سلطنه المساء
المساليد وهي قبيله موجوده وعريقه في هذا
المكان اذا اليوم ايضا الانباء تقول ان
زعيم المساليد سعد عبد الرحمن
قد غادر هو ومجموعه كبيره من اعيان هذه
القبيله الى تشاد هم الان موجودون في تشاد
كما تقول الانباء وبالتالي اتجهت هذه
الحرب في هذه المنطقه الى ان تكون حرب
عرقيه حرب على اسس قبليه وبالتالي هذا
مؤشر الى امكانيه ان يندلع تندلع حرب
اهليه ليست فقط بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع وانما تتنزل الى القبائل والجهويات
والاعراق وبالتالي هذه التداعيات خطيره ان
ذهبت هذه الحرب في هذا الاتجاه شكرا جزيلا
للمسلمين الكباشي مدير مكتب الجزيره من
الخرطوم